Saudi Arabia just pulled off one of the
biggest shake-ups in sporting history
here's why this week's big golf merger
matters and a few questions about what
happens next it's just a year since
Saudi launched the upstart live golf
series but its impact has been so big
that it's forced a shock Union with a
more established PGA and European tours
the new entity essentially puts Saudi
Arabia in charge of world golf it was in
June 2022 that Liv began offering top
players big money and started a fight
over the future of the game a
multi-billion dollar project part of
saudi's wider push to raise its Global
profile major Champions Phil Mickelson
and Dustin Johnson were among those to
be banned by their home tours and
shunned by fellow Pros now spare a
thought for those who spent a year
fighting live golf Tiger Woods was
reportedly offered 800 million dollars
Rory McIlroy 500 million but refused
only for the PGA to join forces with
Saudi without telling anyone for players
I'm not surprised that you know this is
an awful lot to ask them to digest so do
the Loyalists get compensated did the
so-called defectors just get to stroll
back in having pocketed hundreds of
millions of dollars lots of questions
and details to iron out this one is not
over yet
[Music]